Let's go to Manfred from Hong Kong, Manfred
from Hong Kong.
You were on the air.
David, can you hear me?
Yes, I can.
So I was just wondering what the relationship
between China and the US would become and
the bottom line, I think you're going to see
a lot of the trade war aspects dealt with,
although, you know, we have to understand
that at this point, China is likely to sort
of want to negotiate on the removal of tariffs
because what Donald Trump did is crazy.
So I don't you know, there are some who think
it will be as simple as Joe Biden being sworn
in and then saying to China, let's get rid
of all those tariffs.
I don't think it's going to be that that easy.
And I understand why.
But I do think that, you know, Joe Biden is
someone who understands much more about China
than Donald Trump will ever hope to.
And I'm hoping for a normalization of relations.
Yeah, and the other question I have is, throughout
the campaign, Joe Biden always said that he
wants unity and judging from his cabinet.
Do you think he achieved that goal?
Well, listen, this is a beautiful question,
Manfred.
I really appreciate it.
Joe Biden is not going to pick right wingers
to his cabinet, by and large.
Right.
So most of the picks, I think, are very reasonable
people.
Like, as an example, Janet Yellen.
Janet Yellen is a left wing economist, but
she is eminently qualified.
She's an academic, a scholar.
She's not going to do anything crazy.
Nothing that she would support would be socialism.
She's a very reasonable selection.
Now, Neera Tanden, who Joe Biden selected
the left, the progressive left and many on
the right dislike Neera Tanden.
I think it's the opposite of unity.
I think that pick was a disaster.
So I think there's a lot of this and a lot
of that with the selections that Joe Biden
has made so far.
So overall, what do you think?
Overall, I think that Joe Biden's selections
have mostly been, of course, people on the
left, center, left, and as much as one could
expect Republicans to be OK with that, they
have not been controversial selections in
any way.
Oh, yeah, oh, thanks for having me.
Yeah, of course.
So so you're out how how how are things in
Hong Kong right now?
It's been fine and there are a little bit
surge in covid cases.
Yeah, it's yeah, overall it's been fine.
We try to get the local cases down to zero,
but we just can't do it at.
Got it, got it.
And have you been listening to the show, watching
the show for a while?
Yeah, about all girls, I think, since August,
OK.
Yeah, well, Manfred, I really appreciate it.
You're the first caller we've had from Hong
Kong.
Yeah, thanks for having me.
All right, Manfred from Hong Kong, what a
call, what a call.